Society has always infiltrated Sports
think about Muhammad Ali with the
Vietnam War and refusing to enter the
armed services think about Kurt flood
fighting for free agency things that
have not supposedly didn't have anything
to do with sports ended up having
everything to do with sports because
what the athletes and the sports world
was showing you is that we still have to
live in the society once the Game Stop
we look at the Naomi Osaka right now and
they she's playing tennis they see her
get so emotional and then the issue of
mental health and all of this stuff
comes to the Forefront that's the world
that we live in and so when you see
Sports even though it's supposed to be
an escape and that's why people clamor
to it and gravitate to it I like the
fact that societal issues sometimes
infiltrate Sports because it's a
reminder that even though life can be
beautiful and it can be a game life
ain't all about games it's about life